Oh [ __ ] you are hard to look at
like a testicle with teeth you look like
Freddy Krueger face-fucked a
topographical map of Utah
exactly auntie look like an avocado had
sex with an older avocado thank you
hey youtubers is Charlie happy 12 days
of Deadpool so since there hasn't been a
whole lot of new footage I thought I'd
do 10 funny Deadpool moments from the
comics there's so many to pick from so
we could probably do this to the end of
time but here we go just to get started
with this ugly Christmas sweater this is
them [ __ ] on x-men first class which
i think is hilarious
I mean I mean they're just having a
little bit of fun I think this is a
little too soon for them to start
[ __ ] on Fantastic Four but just
expect them to have fun with that with
future Deadpool movies I definitely
think the Deadpool is going to be
successful enough to warrant a sequel so
even though Ryan Reynolds said that he
doesn't want to play any more
superheroes he's really just talking
about other superheroes I think he'd be
happy to come back as Deadpool for a
sequel moving along Deadpool fear itself
just hammer dancing his way into your
hearts the funny thing about this is
like most people nowadays probably have
absolutely no idea who MC Hammer is but
if you saw the Jif of him just dancing
across your screen you would recognize
him instantly you'd be like oh yeah
that's the funny guy with the parachute
pants
they were later renamed to Hammer pants
if you don't remember fear itself it was
a very Thor heavy storyline that crossed
the entire Marvel Universe so that's why
he's holding a bedazzled Thor's hammer
can't touch this Deadpool is an OT Star
Wars purist I actually kind of like the
new films better BAM nope not having it
full disclosure is totally cool if you
want to like the Star Wars prequels I'm
not going to hate on the prequels but I
just love the Deadpool as a hardcore fan
boy how dare you like the prequels so
you which he's a Star Trek purist as
well he's seen every single episode of
Star Trek given his love of original
Star Trek he probably tried to
assassinate the new Star Trek films as
well somebody tell Chris Pine to watch
out for Ryan Reynolds Deadpool knows the
super bro code never a dubrow's secret
identity also remind Peter Parker to
burn that spider-man costume when
Deadpool gives it back is the weekend so
why not Deadpool vs. pancakes normally
the Deadpool vs. chimichangas but given
the x-men apocalypse trailer feel like
Apocalypse Now pancakes is just really
appropriate for younger people who
haven't seen Apocalypse Now I love the
smell of napalm in the morning is just
the quote from Apocalypse Now my actual
favorite Apocalypse Now joke though is
when they had Mark Hamill on the Will
Ferrell era Saturday Night Live it made
him do the fake QVC thing where they
brought him on as himself and made him
do the Apocalypse Now line he's like I'm
not even in that movie but he said it
anyway I love the smell of napalm in the
morning
high-fives the Deadpool high-fives Mark
Hamill
for being a good sport Deadpool is
amazing with children part one stop me
if you've heard this one pull my finger
oh wait up Deadpool is amazing with
children part two you've been having
psychopathic thoughts well here here's
something you can do with that try some
classy magazines definitely gotta give
them bonus points for giving teenage
Apocalypse porn just to help deal with
those special urges to go homicidal on
the entire planet Deadpool vs. Lady
Hawkeye can you help a bro out just yank
this knife right out yank it out
it's totally killing me wait a minute
you're not really dying are you
that's it BAM just sticks the knife
right back in and probably one of the
most inappropriate funny deadpool
moments deadpool goes street fighter on
kitty pryde gotta give him at least a
few bonus points for not giving a crap
about the backlash from hitting a girl
this is actually from an issue where
Deadpool's therapist who has a bell for
a head told him to pick a fight with
wolverine to deal with his dead
girlfriend issues ends up going street
fighter on kitty pryde the even funnier
part about this for me isn't so much
like people reading this and laughing
because it's a funny moment like haha
you know you're hitting kitty pryde it's
like a little kid reading this then his
parents finding out and trying to
explain to him why it's not okay to walk
around uppercutting women to deal with
your issues bonus funny moment deadpool
is an avid user of tumblr which
spider-man apparently has never heard of
we go to different web sites so if you
guys haven't seen it there is a Deadpool
teaser that's coming the night before
Christmas
then another trailer that's coming on
the 25th right on Christmas Day so I'll
be doing videos for both of those there
might even be some more footage coming
before that but I'm not expecting any
we're really in prime Star Wars
territory so if you haven't seen the
movie be sure to go out and see it I've
already done a non-spoilery review but
there are a whole bunch of questions
that everyone has about it like
questions that the movie doesn't answer
so I'm probably gonna do a video for
that then I'll do an Easter Egg video I
was going to do an Easter Egg video
today but I think I'm gonna have to see
at least like two or three more times
before I get them all most of the
biggest Easter eggs are pretty obvious
though so you should be able to spot a
lot of them so white goes wait for my
next video you can click here for my
non-spoiler a Star Wars review don't
worry no spoilers in that video and you
can click here for all my other Deadpool
videos including the 12 days of Deadpool
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you